いつ起き続け
早10位九里ますね
[音楽]
もうすぐ数縛りが表示されますか術です
愛だけで皆さん私の今年一年の縛りことせ自然は動画を撮る際は基本的なスーツを着用
するというでっかい十字架背負ったまま早一年が過ぎようとしております
なんか撮影の時だけスーツとか言いつつも結局被害のいちいちめんどいからずっと
スーツ着てることが多くてなんだもうスーツで寝ることもあったくらいですまあそれが
以降もちょっとスーツというものを今年一年たくさん使ったせいで自分の私服とは何な
のかわからなくなってしまいました具体的に言いますとあの数として来ないね結構し二
脚方しちゃったりして
祝がないんですよ来年からの宿がないマンに着ればいいかは分からないと制服のセンス
もないどうしようということで今回ですね私各200万円企画というものやっていたの
皆さんにご存知でしょうか
商品で1000万円でたんですけどもそれ100万円ずつ使って10回企画をするって
いうのがあったんですけどもその数を数えてみてください与う
1回残っているんですということで勝てるぞ来年に向けて服を100万円部買っちまい
ま奏曲
というわけで何度ですね11月19日本日
公共の守備あのパルコのオープン3ということでですねなーんと
なんだですね人類初の渋谷パルコのお客さんとして買えるものを決定しておりまーす
はいというのもですねあの今渋谷マルコの上の方で華帆のカギともやってるんだよな
そういう感じ相まってちょっと
やばくないですかまずは誰も入ってないお店に初めて僕入れるんですよね他のキャラが
いないんですけども
あっ
かスッキリじゃんすぐあるかすぎるじゃんと一体どこなんですけども
ちょっとしばらくが貸し切り状態みたいなのが続くんですけども後半ちょっとあの
メディアな方とかいろんな関係者の方が来られるんで完全に貸切ではないんですけど
ほぼ事実貸切みたいな状態でございますだけであんな北静岡の誰子にしか行ったこと
ないんで
東京のパルコの力見せてもらえた要するにあの守備アプリ
船につき野菜は全部買われてない状態なんですよ売り切れがないんですオープンだから
店員さんも完璧商品の者などでも完璧最新のトレンドものしか入っていないそんな最強
の渋谷パルコに1人目のお客さんとして北が入って僕に会いそうな柄を選んでもらって
来年からの試宿を100万円分
買おうと思います贅沢では去っすごい z
あああああん
me
ああああああ
re ん
服がなくているんです
お薬の服があったら服に買わせてくるああいらっしゃいます
ございまああつも買う時マジでお勧めなんですよねの1年のブランクがありますね自分
の中のチップというものがたくないなぁー発想なんです
やっぱりでチェーンソーよればそれでいいっ
じゃあまーす
例えばけど
ながらこれからさかカッコ8こんなを切ってないですからねぼく
長らくお値段はこちらは30球なんですよ
ねもうずっ春暁まで持ってくると買った後音が入っていただきますと針も着回しがし
やすいチェスターコート
はいはいこれがらのものもとかもご用意しており
これ
ちょっと攻撃てみてもいないんですねはい一目ぼれってヤツだこれは
ソーニャになりますね
本当ですか
か今初ギャップは何だろうぜばベースが2になっちゃうんだろうなぁ
結構カジュアルな雰囲気で着ていただけるとなるほどだろうねこういうのを聞きながら
切ればそうですね
分かりません少しでも使えそうなんでそれでも本当に今から使っていただけれど
頂きありがとうございですはいもう決定照射を買っちゃいたいですけど最初にはしゃぐ
と好反応が出なくなりそうなのでひとまず落ち着いてい
1点からさせていただきますこれ蛙っていう
[音楽]
シャツを買いましたずっ店舗くらい時間的に行けたんですけど
ば十分くらいの計算ですまず骨でできますし
店舗や70408軽減でございますすればよ
ここまで怒られるどんどん行きましょう
展望やこちらでございますよます
ブーブー1年間 see here あればちょっと火遊びファー
[音楽]
ブーブ待ってもいいクロス
これゆるっとした時あそうなんで買いますちょっブーブーってああいう
昨日かシミュレーションしました本殿からお姉さんのシュミレーションであれば可愛い
かわいい
pop って書いてありますけど会話探して兄ちゃんの一人だぜって入れた方がいいと
思う
こんな感じでよろしいはい私所
ああああああああ新憲法
十分にわずかにを増していく
ただいま2店舗目で金額18万7000ですね若干まで抑え気味であります大丈夫です
ただいまがとうございました勝ったと3点目はルイズさんですいらっしゃいます
それじゃ
おすすめのありまってまっ
しすぐに向けたスクール入ればとなるほどブーブレ
て弱強用衣料良いか結構パンチ効いて迷うんですねえかっこいいっ
プロすっ
切迫ちょっですねー
こちらがいますあーありございます g 18セットアップですもうそうですね
ねすごいなんかセットアップって言葉に心打たれましたありがとうございます俺は今
まで僕きたを行いタイプの服ぜひ練習
はいいただきます
[拍手]
ございますまたウェブセンスがまるで右腕からさえ3店舗に買いましたどんどん次行き
ましょう人に今のところなんですけども3店舗で a さん111,300円です若干
日はいなんでしょ4店舗目ですっげーですねぇー
すみません
けどー
渋谷のこの春をけん制でつく
ペタ検定モデルってやつがずっと限定なんですね
まだで
日本の
これを友達になってなっている
英語引かないんですけどこれかっこいい
そして日本に5個しかないそうなんですけどです
女性ながらだなぁもっかいます
お願いします
時計もゲットしましたどんどん4章今4.5回って4043,300円ですまた
ちょっと
ディファインドです次は抑えたいですねいいお勧められて買っちゃうんですけどは5
店舗目ですベイトさんでございます
金土祝センスタイプなので進められたぜすからかいます
この吉良家私収納術ください
この辺がこっちになって
カーミットが目でリード通っている
[音楽]
さあお使いはございません入った
沿いです買ってきましたん
4日
ありません
ていません
風間さん
ちょっとしたほぼ服ですよね
6店舗名いきましょう出て6店舗目やヌビアさんに
たて言っていただきました早速行きましょうください
すごい市場とな宿がパッと見ではい
言えそうな服があれば是非てっなんてやらないがめっちゃ可愛いこれ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ずうならばまあすごいかわいい
全部これよいって以上リメイクしたよな
こういったと思う
[音楽]
ブーブーパワーこれ一枚で
そしてステーション5分
編んでます
でも者らはめちゃくちゃいいと思います
金も水を切ってから考えますか
[音楽]
100かいは税込みではいこちらになります
76,000円ですねまたしまーす
ドンちゃったーーーー金額がですね6店舗で721050です
ちゃーんちょっと1回抑えに入りますでは7店舗目いきましょう
福武
作った結果敗2分けで7店舗目です via bus stop さんですうんすごい
綺麗な雰囲気が漂っておりますいきましょう
キレイめな服が多い
[音楽]
ねかわいい知ってしまった
tan
バッハはかわいい
[音楽]
本当に向かいますでは
ただいまの合計金額がまた金上がりまして9023,450円列も跡がありませんあと
3店舗けど行く予定なんですけど
70,000円ちょい次高い見てきたら多いですあいちゃげで発展褒めですまずを
エヴァストアさんです
いきましょうまず金がねーんだないやー服をくださいいや
梅崎線ブルー
パスねそうですね私はとある
ほどこね氏はこっちで
ているのである
すごいソウルけどそれでもいいか山道強いと思います
紫紫で5着だった
ラリマーないでしょうかありがとうございました
さあどうございます初店舗目で96万410円です後4万円ぐらいしかないで抑え抑え
すぎます会いたいで9店舗目で加入しさんに来させていただきました
ブービー紀北にゃ
ツクラーだぜっ
すごい子が負けないんですよ全然あのー
よ
ています
ていたないん
これにしますありがとうございます
100円ん
当然伸ばしましたありがとうございます仕上げます
はいというで9店舗目もありました後一転ばから行けそうなんでもう入っちゃいます
進学は最後にお楽しみに
相手を入れ10店舗目ですこちら形成さにておりますハッピー全商品で
いやいそうな金畑教えていただきたい泣けない
こちらございました
これだけ与作時数え new なんかブルゾンとかじゃないかとか思っ
はいと思う
こちらをこの回は生の結構いい計算できて気がするんで
お値段こちらでございました
不満31800写りです
というわけで回論集りゃー
結果もう一杯というわけで100万円分つく買ってきました
なんかあの
[音楽]
高かった抑えが吹くたが学科多いですよ多いですけどなんか僕そんな人の高い来ないん
でもうちょっとたくさん買えるのかなと思ったんですけどもうなんか
県も1着とかが普通みたいなにそれも2着200万円ついバスみたいなものも結構あっ
てびっくりしました
東京コアなぁけどその分素敵な服がたくさんあったんですけどもまぁそんな彼の
ゆりセグリアお店の方に選んで頂いて無事100万円分服買うことができました
これは違うんですけどよくさっそく見ていきましょう宛てがお値段全部出ないくらい
だったんだろうけ術での合計金額
のところ
答えてるを搭載する99万6,490円約100万円会社フルこれだけみよう
これはガチで買わなきゃいけないと思ってしまうフラット1個って言ったんでねこんな
こと言われたらもう株しかないでしょう
うわぁ4万円したんですけどもこれはもう買わざるを得なかったですねかもう耳が
無理やりかなマジですて p ってレベルは上ですけどそこにいてもらいましょう
会場でちょっとか霧多布ちょっと来てみようと思います水 kef たくさんですけど
もあの
すぐ北になったことがこれでしたねこれならえんだってだってくれだった18万20万
よこれ20万円ロックボタン撮り
あらそれ一個で3万円とかでしょやかなって思いますね
俺はまずで可愛いと思いましたねここは長いのがすごいかわいいですねこれが20万円
ですねもこいつのシャッターはあんまり持ってないからねマジで助かる
マーベル酒と女ってこれで問題で4万は超えてくれると思いますいやーかっこいいなぁ
いやいやああああ全然白い服とか
はいけないんですけどこういうのも全然アリだと思います悪くないでこれが18番とか
ですね疑いよがんばって生粉打ちょっとはこれも良いですね
このここがすごい黒いのがカッコイイと思います高校の変化が俺は着ない服のジャンル
ですね皆さんこれが
セットアップってやつですなんだかよくわかりませんそして忘れていけないのはこちら
で世界に5個しかない時計なんですよ
高い9度なぁさりげないんだよなめちゃくちゃ俺これめっちゃ使うと思いますまた
可愛いスニーカーを買ったんですよねこれ煽りに使いこなせるか分からならそして
エヴァコラボです黄色いフル板ばいけないんですけどねまぁちょっと来年ため
してみようかなと思いますねウエブ声なんかボクっぽい気がしますきやすいですこう
いうものが巻ないから
本舗たい取り上げるこれぐらい結構服買いました
うーん
服着たいなぁというわけですねあのスーツスーツすぐ visit して良かったん
ですけども1年間を通して動画の会的にちょっとつまんなくなっちゃったかっていうの
はの正直な反省点ですっ youtube で打つで仕事なんで
まあそういう服装とかでねちょっともうちょっと見てる人を楽しませて出たらよかった
なっていうのがまた一つばかり正
したユーチューバー服大事だよねー飽きさせないように通される気を使って相片からは
いろんな服を着ようと思いますだけど皆さん
来年お楽しみに
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ